[Musica]
cari tutti mi chiamo marco molto e sino
a poco tempo fa aveva una vita normale
oggi non è più così
e questo il motivo per cui sono qua a
raccontarvi un sogno che unisce scienza
e spiritualità
il tema ted per padova di quest'anno e
libris ovvero portarsi al di là dei
propri limiti
sino a sfidare gli dei apparentemente
sembrerebbe infatti che io voglia
sfidarli ma sarebbe una sfida complicata
perché in verità non è chiaro chi siano
questi dei e quanti tutti gli abbiano e
allora proveremo a capirci qualcosa di
più
basandoci su ciò che sappiamo dai loro
creato l'universo e la vita questa
misteriosa realtà che guardate
attentamente sembra irreale quanto un
sogno
siamo spesso propensi a pensare che
tutto sia stato creato per noi esseri
umani ma in questi ultimi secoli la
scienza ci ha dato preziosi risposte che
hanno gradualmente ridimensionato il
nostro ruolo nel cosmo
una volta in twitter la misteriosità
dell'universo ci siamo ritrovati
piccolissimi e significanti in una scala
spaziale temporale inimmaginabile per la
nostra mente e ci siamo resi conto di
non poter conoscere il presente poiché
possiamo solamente osservare il passato
alzate gli occhi al cielo fissati una
stella a caso ciò che state vedendo è
già accaduto anni fa ho anche migliaia
di anni fa il tempo necessario affinché
la luce dalla arrivi sino a 9
come disse carl sagan che siamo abbiamo
scoperto che viviamo su un pianeta
insignificante di una stella banale
sperduta in una galassia nascosta in un
angolo dimenticato di un universo in cui
le galassie sono di gran lunga più
numerosa delle persone ed è proprio così
cari miei non siamo speciali e saremmo
veramente presuntuosi se pensassimo di
poter sfidare gli dei
siamo parte di un maestoso progetto che
talvolta appare perfettamente coerente
matematico per volta un sogno assurdo
quando ci svegliamo il mattino passiamo
dalla realtà creata dalla nostra mente
durante il sonno a quella che dovrebbe
essere la vera realtà fatta in gran
parte di materia ed energia oscura di
cui non sappiamo sostanzialmente nulla
in questa strana realtà mi trovo isolato
sono una tra le 26 persone più isolate
del pianeta terra attorno invece
solamente una immensa e piatta distesa
di neve che arriva sino all orizzonte in
ogni direzione
vorrei camminare scoprire cosa c'è oltre
ma è molto complicato per qualche motivo
gli dèi hanno reso questo posto il pin
ospitale isolato al mondo tant'è che per
altri nove mesi nessuno può raggiungermi
né per visitarmi né per soccorrermi
quale riesce care ferite fanno fatica a
cicatrizzarsi i miei piedi pugliano
sopra uno strato di tre chilometri di
ghiaccio neve e c'è poco ossigeno perché
l'aria è rarefatta come a circa 4.000
metri dal test alla da voi
la temperatura in questo momento di meno
70 gradi centigradi ed è destinata a
scendere perché il sole appena andato
via
saranno le sue sorelle brillare in cielo
durante una lunga notte che terminerà
tra quasi quattro mesi nel mi chiedo
perché le consideriamo privi di vita
perché pretendiamo di sapere cose vita e
cosa non lo è
cosa rende speciale ciò che per noi è
fitta all'interno di un universo che sua
volta potrebbe essere una minuscola
parte di un qualcos'altro
se dovessi attenermi alla nostra
concezione di vita
e allora qua dove mi trovo non ce ne
sarebbe fatta eccezione per me ed i miei
12 compagni in ambiente extraterrestre
tant'è che spesso sento di vivere
altrove in qualche angolo del cosmo
lontano dalla terra
non a caso l'agenzia spaziale europea
complesso di noi degli studi di biologia
umana vorrebbe capire come il corpo
reagisce in condizioni estreme in modo
da pianificare al meglio le future
missioni spaziali che il destino mi ha
portato qua per osservare il cielo
riflettere e probabilmente capite ciocco
intendo perché come disse stephen
hawking se come me avete rivolto lo
sguardo alle stelle e avete cercato di
trovare un senso a ciò che vedete anche
voi avete cominciato a chiedere di che
cosa faccia esistere l'universo è così
nel silenzio lontano dalla vita cerco di
capire qual è il sogno e qual è la
realtà
il senso di tutto ciò il mistero che
avvolge un sistema allo stesso tempo
logico è il logico matematico e
razionale inavvicinabile per la mia
mente ti mando un caloroso abbraccio una
concordia station una base di ricerca
scientifica isolata all'interno del
continente antartico
[Musica]